so
hi everyone i am this is
priyana trajan i am the current director
of the frankie program
and i'm delighted to invite you all to
the discussion session that
uh follows our uh talk yesterday
uh so yesterday we had as part of our
monthly colloquium
series in the understanding the nature
of inference project
we had a talk titled experiments
uh for causal inference and system
identification
by um professor nihat ai and
as per custom uh the day after the talk
um we have uh arranged to have sort of a
conversation
and uh discussion between our speaker
and an invited interlocutor and i'm
really thrilled that the interlocutor we
have today to speak to professor i
is professor kyle cranmer who is a
physicist
um as well as um someone who is at the
cutting edge of
applying data data science and machine
learning
to understanding sort of the complex
physics data landscape his background is
in particle physics but i
found for those of you who are
interested we'll add and link to this
in fact kyle is going to be speaking
later on in our series
as well but he has a fabulous paper that
came out
in pnas that really looks at the
question of
inference from simulations and uh
i i learned a lot from that work and i'm
really thrilled to have the two of you
converse so
uh welcome neha welcome kyle and take it
away please
great thank you very much um so uh yeah
so i put together a few slides just to
kind of uh
kick-start the the discussion and also
you know in case anyone
uh wasn't able to uh see all of the talk
yesterday so let me
share those slides i won't go on i won't
drone on for too long um and then
and then we can get to the more
interesting part of the discussion
what a gorgeous graphic thank you yeah
this is a
a collision event at the large hadron
collider where these very high energy
particles collide in the center here and
and all of these uh new particles come
flying out into the detector and while
it's a computer graphic it's a
visualization of an actual collision
ironically it's with my competitor
experiment the cms experiment while i
work on
the atlas experiment but they do have a
good graphics department so
i don't take advantage of um so uh yeah
so this is a conversation with professor
niha i
and so first i'll just start by you know
uh
showing his his outline and the uh
and the uh kind of flyer that we had so
again this is part of this uh
multi-disciplinary exploration of uh the
nature of inference
uh correlation and causation i think
it's a really interesting uh
series of talks and i'm very happy to be
a part of it um
and uh so professor i really talked
about you know
really the core canon around uh around
causal inference
and uh and so the outline was here um we
didn't get to
everything so some of these really
interesting things at the end we didn't
get to
uh but uh we did uh get to go through
kind of like a lot of the core
uh about this idea of identifiability of
causal effects
and i'm not going to you know repeat
anything that he said
but i will just kind of uh kind of
rewind a little bit i would say
and say that when we're talking about
inference uh you know there's
a lot of times the way that i'm thinking
of it is you know as a physicist we have
very
predictive models and those predictive
models are tied to this idea of
mechanism
and uh when we talk about causal
diagrams and things like this
we're often talking about you know
mechanistic models um and so it's really
kind of science and an old-school way
where you really think you understand
what's going on underneath and so i
think of a theory is basically having
some parameters here i call them theta
and for me they might be things like the
mass of the higgs particle or you know
the cosmological
constant or something and i'm trying to
use that theory to predict what i would
expect the data to look like
and oftentimes that's done you know
probabilistically i don't i'm not saying
the data is going to be exactly this
it's a distribution for the data
and then given some observed data i want
to turn it around and do inference on
the parameters theta
and so that's there we go you see how
inference is kind of this inverse of the
predictive direction and oftentimes
people refer to these as
inverse problems now
this is a kind of wikipedia level
picture of the scientific method
of course you know when we're you know
inference in some sense is just one
piece of the scientific method where we
have some data in hand
and we're trying to infer those
parameters of the theory
for whatever experiment or set of
observations we happen to have done
of course the scientific method is much
more dynamic we're constantly
developing new hypotheses trying to
figure out how to test them
building new experiments so it's there's
a lot more going on and so inference is
really kind of
one particular uh you know aspect of of
this process
um and that uh but the role of theory
also kind of
you know contrasts against a lot of the
buzz that was happening i guess now it's
been uh you know a few years
this is a paper uh and and wired i guess
from 2008
but when big data was like all the rage
there was this idea that big data was
going to make a theory irrelevant
right and that uh and that the
scientific method would be obsolete
um and some of these ideas were
furthered by you know in these ideas of
like the fourth paradigm there's a
famous quote from peter norvig at google
talking about
you know it's a riff off of this famous
quote that all models are wrong
and saying all models are wrong and
increasingly you can get a
get by without them um and that's
essentially saying that if you have a
lot of data
maybe you just don't need them okay and
so this very much comes from a mentality
that certainly you would see
in something like google where your
emphasis is largely on prediction you
know
given some data can i predict you know
someone's going to click on an
ad or something like that um and now
so the kind of counterpoint to that has
been uh you know led
largely by uh judea pearl uh and
and you know many other people um but he
has written for instance a very
well-known book called the book of why
um and and he's you know done a very
good job of communicating
um uh the um uh this uh
uh the the deficiencies and this kind of
purely data-driven way of uh going about
things
and he's described what he's called the
the ladder of causation
and so there's sort of three different
rungs on this ladder
association intervention and
counterfactuals and professor i talked a
lot about
intervention um and uh and somehow kind
of a little bit the
relationship between these two i'll just
say a little bit more about
uh association so association
you know to me is is largely what
how i thought of statistics uh you know
prior to learning more about causal
inference uh
and the idea that you have random
variables and you uh
you know you observe them and uh and
there might be a there's a distribution
for them
and if you have many of them you want to
for instance understand you know how
they're correlated
and you know the best you could possibly
do is know that exactly the joint
distribution
over some data and that would be maybe
in the limit of an infinite amount of
data so you're not talking about big
data you're talking about like the
idealized
infinite amount of data setting and
what's become clear now
is that the types of questions that you
can answer
with data alone are restricted and that
there's a broader class of questions
that you can address
but to answer them you have to include
data
and some assumptions and and those
assumptions can come in various forms
but when you're talking about causal
inference it usually comes in the form
of one of these causal
uh causal graphs and uh
and so you know i think some people
would maybe you know
wouldn't necessarily want to accept this
at first but the the nice part of what's
happening is you're getting just many
examples that make it you know kind of
clear that uh there's no way you're
going to be able to answer
these questions so association i may ask
for clarification
so when you are talking about when you
talk uh mentioned
theories previously um are you talking
does theory
include simulations as well like
theoretical expectations that are
um time evolved and so on are are you
really
talking about so if you take particle
physics so if you're looking at one of
those collisions as our sort of
test case so would the theory be
the standard model and the expectations
of all the particles that you expect out
of an
interaction um i want to understand like
what is the starting point there can it
be simulations do you see
the other is the simulation lattice gate
simulations for example right so
those are instantiations of a
theoretical prediction so do you make a
distinction between the two or are you
going to lump them
into one thing as theory yeah
i think you could uh yeah and here i
guess maybe
like maybe the label here is even kind
of bad the theory in some sense these
are really just the parameters of the
theory on the far left
to me i guess i would say that uh a
simulation
you know is is often time like you you
have a theory you may be able to write
it on a piece of paper or something it's
usually some kind of you know maybe
some platonic ideal but in a
but the theory connected with a concrete
experimental uh you know scenario or
observational scenario
uh should be the thing that allows you
to make predictions for what you think
the data will look like
right um and so then the the way that
you actually go about making the
predictions there's details there you
know it might be a pencil and paper
calculation it might be a simulation
but you have uh you've you've somehow
and and i'm that's an important part you
know and a lot of practical
issues arise in that uh but but to me i
guess i think of the theory as
whatever it is that you need to be able
to make uh predictions about the data
you know when coupled with a concrete
you know uh
observational or experimental setting
right so i mean the reason i ask is
right because if you look at cosmology
or astronomy versus particle physics the
one of the issues is the particular role
or
epistemic role of simulations themselves
we cannot do any controlled experiments
in cosmology right
and in particle physics you are able to
do these controlled experiments so i was
just very curious
whether these arrows that you sort of
nicely
uh sketched out for us they permit that
flexibility or is there something
different that happens in a field when
you can't
make uh when you can't replicate
yeah no i think a lot happens there and
i didn't you know prepare anything
for that uh for that particular i mean
uh
uh aspect of it and and the
the let's see what you say i mean in a
more refined version of this picture i
would you know i would start to tease
apart the theory and the pieces that are
like the parts you really care about
and then parts that describe you know
whatever else you need to be able to
make predictions about the data so they
may have to do with your instrument they
may have to do with a lot of
for instance uncertain astrophysics that
you have no idea about
and so that starts to introduce these
ideas of like nuisance parameters and
things like this so
so to me that in some sense the way i'm
using the word theory loosely
includes both the part that you really
care about as a scientist
and all the other dissiderata that you
need to include
to include the make a prediction of the
data and that part might be highly
uncertain
right um and then and then the
difference about being able to do
repeated experiments where you can
actually kind of control the
circumstances versus a kind of a purely
observational
setting that is uh
that's also going to have a huge
influence on you know what types of
inference you're going to be
and it's going to uh limit you i i don't
know that i would
separate that really from how i think
about the theory per se okay um
but but you would but there's a lot less
you can do
and that touches a little bit on the
ideas of interventions that we're
getting to but okay great
no i just wanted a little bit of uh
clarification um
to to understand if this um
this looping and the connection the way
in which
prediction and inference themselves are
related
uh alters depending on you know if you
have
um uh theories that
uh deal with data that is not replicable
right so i was curious whether but it
sounds like
um these arrows and their directionality
uh remain as they are but what you can
infer
gets affected deeply depending on okay
that's i think that's how i would i
would phrase it
uh you know in in terms of like at the
higher level
not this inference task but at the
higher level like this kind of
scientific
method approach if you're able to repeat
experiments or change circumstances
obviously you're going to have a much
more powerful
you know set of tools available to you
but that already kind of points at
what's going on a little bit is if you
think of it
you know the association level is
largely kind of this picture you have
data
and you're kind of like you know if a
theory gives you a joint distribution on
the data
then you know everything that there is
to know and you're going
and and uh and in some sense there's
nothing more to the story
and if you had like an infinite amount
of data then like you know it should
just
reduce to you know mathematics and
calculus it's not much more to the story
but we somehow as scientists we know
there's a lot more to the story and your
example about
you know observational versus you know
controlled experiments
points to the fact that they're
different but somehow that difference is
not lying just in this picture
it's lying in the broader setting of uh
what can we do as scientists
right and uh yeah great well thank you
verification
yeah no it's a great i mean it's it's
great uh great question um and uh you
know something that we could talk about
for
hours and hours so um so i don't want to
go on too long but i do want to motivate
a little bit more
so um so this was kind of the you know
the big data
early machine learning uh and also a lot
of the data science and machine learning
narratives have been about
you know around this kind of idea that
maybe data can solve all of our problems
um and uh and so yeah and as i mentioned
there's kind of
uh this in this ladder of causality uh
that
a lot of that thinking is really stuck
at the lowest rung here of association
and that there are kinds of questions
you're basically just not going to be
able to answer
and there's a broader set of questions
that you're going to be able to address
but they are going to kind of require
assumptions and those assumptions are
usually
uh you know encoded in like a a
graphical
or a causal model right um and so okay
so this is just zooming in on kind of
what kinds of questions you're asking
and uh
and so um you know associations are
largely like if i knew x you know how
does it change my belief and why
and those are things kind of like
conditional distributions and a lot of
prediction tasks can be
cast this way um but intervention
is asking a kind of question like you
know uh what if i do
you know something you know what's going
what's going to happen so the example
here is if i take an aspirin
you know will my headache be cured um
you know and like what will happen
if you make a policy change or something
like that and it could be something like
uh
you know i don't know what will happen
if i point my telescope in the side of
the
of the of the sky or you know what will
happen if i change the energy of the
beams colliding at the large hadron
collider
things like this and and so you're going
in and you're intervening and you're
doing something
and counterfactuals are kind of another
level that are very similar
but they the the main difference here is
that you you're not necessarily
able to go make that intervention uh
like in the examples it gave before you
i can decide to take the aspirin or not
uh here's an example that's like you
know uh if i had taken an aspirin
would it have stopped my headache and it
sounds like it's just a grammar but the
fact that it's represented in our
grammars
shows how important it is right these
are you know
things that i can't do i can't i can't
actually make this intervention
so i have to uh so how you answer a
question like this
is more difficult and it's a little bit
tied to like imagination you have to
kind of
uh you're not going to actually collect
data under these circumstances
you're going to have to kind of imagine
them and that imagination you know does
kind of make you think about simulations
a bit as well right
so um so if you have a causal model you
can kind of start to probe these sorts
of questions
but what you're going to be able to do
with actual data is going to be
restricted
um and so then just to kind of close the
loop a little bit is if you look at you
know
leaders the thought leaders and for
instance deep learning and machine
learning like yeshua bingio
you know they're looking at like what
are the bottlenecks for things like deep
learning that's not that they don't have
enough data
but you have things like you know you're
a classifier of if it's a cat or a dog
or your
your uh automatic driving car system uh
might you know you train it and it might
work pretty well but then when you apply
it to real world images or real world
data
it might not perform well and that might
be because
the that's what's sometimes referred to
as a domain
shift okay and so um so the question is
you know if if uh a lot of the machine
learning things that just take advantage
of
of you know correlations if you change
the distribution a little bit they may
behave in a way that you don't want them
to
and so the claim here is like okay well
what if we like structure our machine
learning things so that they
uh you know have some causal mechanism
and if we've got it right
then the hypothesis is that basically
it's going to take less data
and you're going to be more robust and
have all these great things that
that people care about and these are the
things that are kind of on the way to
something more like
artificial intelligence than just kind
of a
kind of a curve fitting picture of
machine learning
um so with that like a little intro
professor i basically walked us through
you know a lot of the technology and
that you know about how this works
showed us the graphical models uh uh
these bayesian networks uh
gave us a you know mathematical
formalism and introduced a lot of the
really core concepts
um one of the points that he raised and
i think this is one of the things that's
really important is that
when you think about a data distribution
there's sort of two ways to think of it
one is
to think of it as just a big joint
distribution that's kind of
agnostic about how the data got there
and the other way is to think of a data
generating process right so you know it
can literally be time
or it can be you know some you know
abstraction of that but you uh
you have something that's producing the
data um and what's interesting is that
here are
uh you know you know three different uh
uh
causal diagrams that all tell a
different story about how the data got
there
and they may have the same uh joint
distribution but the
the story the narrative you know the
mechanism is different in the different
cases
and so the question is you know how can
i sort of tell them apart if ultimately
i care about this mechanism
and so here i think a toy example can be
super useful so i
took it from this blog post which is
really nice and it's just making two
dimensional data
and i don't want to scare you with
programming but hopefully this is like
simple enough that you have a random
variable x
and then you you calculate you calculate
a new variable y and there's three
different
very simple programs that make variables
x and y
and and they what's interesting is they
all give you exactly the same joint
distribution so from the point of view
of association they're identical
but they have three different stories
about how you get there and you might
think
well who cares these are just like
different you know different ways to
make the data
um but they correspond to different uh
graphical models
um and uh these directed ones so that
have a causal story
and then uh professor i went through
these ideas of the do calculus and
interventions and the do operation
and try to explain to us like why that's
different than just simply conditioning
and here uh you know and then also
showed that uh
that you know while you might be very
difficult to actually do those
interventions if you know something
about this graph
you can kind of predict what would
happen if you do an intervention
and it's exactly the fact that there are
two different
strategies one which is actually doing
the intervention and seeing what happens
and the other is that you think you can
predict what would happen
if you know the underlying uh you know
causal graph
that's kind of the important part right
and so that's uh that's what you see
here is that in some of these equations
on the left you see for instance the do
operation and on the right you you uh
you see things that are look more like
uh
you know you know conditional
distributions and things like this put
together in various ways
and so he went through a few different
examples of this and i'm not going to
go through through all of that just kind
of reminding some
some plots but in this toy example
what's interesting and this also
ties into simulations is that the way
that you can think about intervention
is that okay uh you know i'm going to
generate this random variable x
and what i want to do is understand the
intervention where i set
x equal to three so that's this do
operation i'm going to set x
equal to three intervene sort of like
i'm going to force the person to take
the aspirin
um and what you would think of is like
okay you generate the random x like i
decide that maybe i don't want to take
the aspirin
but i'm going to intervene and say no
you are taking the aspirin right so
you're
you're setting x equal to three and then
basically in every step of the program
you're just going to make sure
x is equal to three and if you do that
then the distribution that you get out
you know x is going to be equal to three
no surprise there
but the interesting part is the
distribution for y is not the same
in these different cases and that's the
statement that the intervention
the you know the do operation is not the
same as conditioning and
here you see it just in a very explicit
example
and so but this is like you know very
simple one and the question is you know
how do you scale this
up and this is where you know professor
i's research is really focused is all
these you know
wonderful theorems that kind of talk
about how to extend this to even to very
complicated situations
um and i won't say more um i won't say
this about
counterfactuals he did give some nice
examples about these like front door and
backdoor
examples uh gave examples in the context
of robotics and
artificial life um this example made me
uh you know made me think of some work
that i'd seen from deepmind on
reinforcement learning where they
uh you know in reinforcement learning
you know they have like an agent for
instance trying to explore
some world that looks like an atari game
or something
and uh and they had an example where uh
the training data
you know is is uh the way that the
reinforcement learning algorithms are
usually trained is at the association
level and it makes a mistake
and they tried to come in and fix that
mistake through this backdoor adjustment
which is
you know very much like uh what we see
here so um so this is just to kind of
reinforce that
these ideas of causal imprints are
really at the cutting edge of like
way that people are thinking about
moving machine learning kind of from
where it was with its first era of
big data and supervised learning and you
know deep learning to
something a little bit more towards
artificial intelligence which is going
and i think increasingly recognize
that uh causal inference is going to be
a major part of the story
so that that was my little intro i
apologize if that went on
too long um and uh so i'll stop there
and maybe the first question is just to
ask professor i
if uh i completely butchered this story
or if uh
uh it seemed like a reasonable uh
compliment to what you what you
presented to us yesterday
so thank you so much that was a great
summary
and extension of what i have
presented yesterday so actually i had
the feeling yesterday that it's
my my presentation was a bit technical
and my intention was to begin this
conversation with the
kind of intuitive explanation of what i
have talked about yesterday
but you already gave that that
overview you summarize you're
summarizing the main points of my
presentation in a very
clean and intuitive and nice way so
thank you so much for that
so um um
yeah so you highlighted you highlighted
the
the main components of of the theory
or the main messages that uh that i was
that i intended to actually uh tell
yesterday
um but you are you also actually
um the beginning of your presentation
uh is uh related to this data science
idea
it's it's very interesting uh so when
you
when you do um
in the context of a generative uh model
so you have a neural network and the
intention
often is to to so you have to
the data coming from from the world okay
and they is let's talk about the sensor
so we have the sensors and you have some
joint distribution generated by the
world
okay and you try to intrinsically
provide some explanation for that
the generative neural network let's say
it's a layered
layered deep neural network and
it's trained in a way
that it can actually explain the data so
it can generate the same distribution
as the distribution generated by by the
world
and then the question is to what extent
can we
so both on both sides of the sensors
so the world and the the neural network
can be represented in terms of a causal
network so neural network is a special
kind of causal network
and then there is the causal network of
the world that is generating the data
and we should not confuse and i think
you
you implicitly made that statement you
should not confuse the
causal network or
our ability to generate the data from
inside
in terms of the neural network with the
understanding
of the underlying causal structure of
the world so knowing the neural network
the causal structure of the neural
network does not tell us anything about
the causality
structure of the of the world so both of
them
are able to generate the same
distribution on the on the periphery so
to say
and that's an interesting that's an
interesting point so that shouldn't be
confused so if i'm able to actually
predict the data
there might be many many possible
solutions to that
and and i think
the the world is one solution but the
network itself is also one solution
the theorem that i presented at the end
of my
uh my talk yesterday basically tells
us um
what kind of structural requirements we
need in order to be able to generate
that distribution so in terms of so if
if the generated distribution has high
uh redundancy let's say a particular
kind of redundancy
that cannot be generated by any network
so it does tell us something
put some constraints on both sides so to
say of the periphery
right so i had a quick question here so
i mean the question often when we are
dealing with the kinds of data sets that
we
are dealing with say you know or
modeling right
is the discrimination between the
solutions
and so one advantage in physics so as i
was talking about yesterday
working on the black hole growth problem
or whatever so you actually have
physical
principles that are going to constrain
the
world sort of the map of solutions that
are offered
so some of them are going to be
unphysical some of them are not going to
tally with symmetries that physics the
underlying fundamental physics
so do you think that this process of
um this inference process
deeply depends on the kind of data that
we have and the relationship
between the world and the neural network
that is
getting the information from the world
because
in in fields like physics we know there
are these principles right that
constrain and restrain
so what is the role i mean so are these
do you
see physical laws as do functions
or are they what are
so that's a very important point so um
the whole uh so i introduced the notion
of a mechanism
yeah which is which is basically markov
chain but that can be
any markov chain so there was no i did
not provide any justification of a part
any distinction between physical and
non-physical markov kernels so all of
them
can be realized in terms of physics but
so observationally let's say let's take
the most simple case you have x and y
and you have an arrow from x to y
observation you cannot distinguish this
from an arrow from y to x okay
but if you compute the conditional
distribution of y given x and
the conditional distribution of x given
y
you you might have additional
information coming from physics
which tell which tells you that one of
these
directions cannot be actually uh
considered as being physically plausible
okay that is an additional information
that i did not
incorporate into my analysis yesterday
but
it plays an important role uh so it
could be for example that you have
a whole set of observationally
equivalent markov equivalent
graphs but only some of them
are physically justifiable right and
that is actually the basis of the group
in tubingen
uh around bernhard sherkov
uh who basically say them we have to
understand
the the primitives so to say this this x
y
example and they basically argue
um that the the direction the right
direction
uh has to have low complexity so physics
prefers low complexity
so you compute the p of y given x and
the p of x given y
and then you you can consider take for
example the markov kernel and the
kolmogorov complexity of that markov
kernel
of both of them and then you prefer the
one that has
the smaller convo of complexity and the
criterion is that the smaller kolmogorov
uh uh complex complexity that that
would reflect the more physical uh
directions
and that of course as you say restricts
uh it's a further argument in order to
be able to distinguish between
observationally equivalent
graphs but that's something so i don't
think that they provide a physical
argument
but i think it's an important direction
so columnar golf complexity might not be
the right
right quantity to take but i think i
think the
argument
[Music]
may be related to something like the
second law of thermodynamics i was just
going to say it sounds like entropy
it sounds right yeah so that would allow
you to actually
distinguish further but that's that's a
whole
a new argument that i did not talk about
yesterday
right kyle did you want to weigh in on
this
yeah i think it's uh yeah i mean well
you know the the notion of
it being low complexity in some notion
of complexity i think is
just a very natural version that's
something like outcomes razor or minimum
description length
it's like you know has many many forms
and it's somewhat natural that you know
it's basically just saying if the
fundamental mechanisms are simple uh it
gets a little complicated and that you
might have very simple fundamental
mechanism but if that you're not
observing at that granularity
then then the aggregate effect of that
is could be some super complicated thing
and so then you know that it's not clear
that the that
the the right causal arrow and the wrong
causal error is gonna
manifest itself in terms of some
complexity measure if you're not seeing
like the
actual mechanism but you know that's a
that's its own that's a very interesting
discussion um one thing that i was going
to say
in in my own kind of as i started going
down the rabbit hole of causal inference
is just trying to you know understand
you know at a very
you know uh almost like sociological
level
is me as a physicist um how is it that i
don't know about causal inference
you know the term causality is uh is
you know baked into being a physicist
you know cause and many
and also so many of the examples that
you see you know
they people go back to thinking about
physical examples or you know
and talk about scientists and and so i
was trying to reconcile
how is it that you know this thing that
seems to be so important for the
scientific method and so closely related
to being a physicist
um is something that i'm from a
mathematical
point of view don't feel you know is not
familiar has never taught about causal
inferences
in my physics classes and uh and so i
think
part of that is that you know well two
tooth where i landed on that as to two
things one is that
we we take it for almost for granted and
it is so much a part of our thinking
uh and it is very much a part of why
physicists have been successful you know
if you go back to this
uh you know if you think about the
scientific process as like an in
the language of ai we've had almost no
data
and almost no compute for the history of
human civilization
to have learned so much about how the
universe works right and the only way
that we got there
was not through you know deep learning
or something right it was
it was uh through exploiting causal
structure and assumptions about causal
structures i'm like totally
you know you know convinced that the
only way that we got to where we are is
by exploiting that
over and over and over again so it seems
to me very important
at the same time you know i don't really
i don't know about this
language i'm learning but like you know
i didn't know about the language of the
do calculus and stuff
and so why is that and i think it's
partially because the causal structure
and so many physics problems
is obvious it's that you know there
might be very uncertain components but
like i know that
whatever happened in the star happened
first and like
the it on the way through the dust and
the galaxy happened next and then
through the atmosphere it was next and
then the telescope
and then the you know and then my data
analysis pipeline the causal structure
is usually really obvious
and when you get into situations like
medicine or social sciences
and things like this the causal
structure is far from obvious
you know you have no idea what's doing
what and people disagree
and so there in order to make progress
you really
had to develop uh the calculus
to be able to manipulate these things
which are not at all like they're very
counterintuitive a lot of times right
even though you needed a very formal
description
yeah yeah you sort of really nailed it i
think
in physics it's a lot more intuitive in
a way
um but for these other disciplines you
need to
formalize the structure and and order it
right and order it as you said one of
the interesting things in the example
that you gave
i mean there is never ambiguity it is
never a question that once the photons
are released
all the filters through which they have
to go through to reach us
right and the fact what follows what
is uh pretty patently clear right yeah
yeah i think so and
um and then you know the
yeah so i think so that that part's
interesting there are i guess
there are a few other things from a
physics point of view that are they
become interesting for a causal
environment so
one of them i'll just mention is that uh
is that
if you think about something like uh
thermodynamics and equilibrium
that's a situation where like you know
you have like the ideal gas law
like pressure you know pressure and
volume and the the temperature
uh you know pv equals nrt and it's just
an equation and so many things in
and physics are written as equations e
equals m c squared you know they're all
there
and and there's no causal direction
there and i don't just mean in the
deeper sense that like our first talk
about you know kind of the arrow of time
but i just mean
it's just an equality right and so i
think it's interesting
because a i think a lot of times when we
write equations like that
we're basically making a mistake what we
when we write those equations we really
mean
something like the inferred value from
these other things you know our
you know equal and like almost like a
maximum likelihood sense but the other
part is that the uh
and and something like you know if you
push down on the piston
and the temp you know the volume goes
down and the temperature goes up like uh
you know who's causing what it's pretty
clear you're pushing you're
you're pushing on it right you know and
so um but in other cases like i heat it
up and then the piston goes up right
it's the same relationship but the
causal story
goes uh kind of in a different direction
and
and what's a little interesting to me
there is that it goes back to the first
talk if you think about coarse grainings
and macroscopic structure versus
microscopic structure
you know a lot of the way that that
first seminar was was
we see causality in the microscopic but
when you go to the
micros sorry and the you see causality
in the macroscopic world but when you go
to the microscopic world
it may it goes away because you have the
you know time reversible dynamics
but the the equilibrium one is a little
bit the opposite story
the macroscopic story is kind of not
really clear what the
causal thing is because you're always in
equilibrium and there's no real causal
graph that's obvious
um but if you could zoom in and see like
the atoms bouncing around or something
like that
uh you know at some mesoscopic course
grading you would see
like which way you know who's causing
what right you know you have you're out
of equilibrium for a little bit
and you know what's happening um so i
think that
that part as a physicist is kind of
interesting uh and then
the other question is like you know in
the do calculus what if i wanted to like
intervene and set like the energy of a
particle to something without
modifying its momentum right if i did
that like i would break
the uh you know the laws that say how
energy and momentum are related the
on-shell conditions so
there are a lot of interventions that
don't you know if i have a simulator
in principle i could go in there and
change those numbers but they don't make
any sense physically
so there's a in addition to the causal
arrows maybe being physical or not
some interventions don't seem you know
realizable and so there's a whole i
don't i'm not part of the discussion
i don't know much about it but i know
there's a lot of like philosophical
debates about
interventions and the do calculus and
what does it mean if you can't actually
make that intervention
so i'd be curious to hear professor i
talk about that a little bit because i
don't
really know about it yeah so that's a
very
uh interesting subject and i
don't think it's uh it's fully resolved
so there is of course in physics uh not
only directed in
uh interaction but also un uh undirected
like like uh the ising model
you have undirected interactions and i
think
uh so that's one thing uh i didn't talk
about that
there is some work trying to actually
rela uh
explain undirected interactions uh
in terms of many many many directed
interactions so like
integrated phenomenon so to say uh but
the theory uh is not
um i i don't
uh so uh my intention is that it's not
settled right
the question is not simple it's it's not
settled so that's one thing it's not
settled
but then there's also physical
constraints
which is maybe a special case of uh
functional constraints so you cannot
change one variable without changing the
other one
and that's exactly the problem that we
had in the context of robotics so we
have really constraints physical
constraints
and physical constraints apply
[Music]
um
imply um that many configurations have
zero probability
okay and this is why you cannot wait
why you cannot actually uh compute the
conditional distribution and
as i said yesterday so this uh this uh
either
this identifiability problem really
requires strict positivity of the
of the joint distribution and when you
have these physical constraints
uh you don't have this uh strict
positivity so they don't hold anymore
this identifiability uh equations that i
presented yesterday
so it's it's a limitation of the theory
i would say
yeah it's also i think i mean going back
to carlo rivelli's
you know uh talk on the first one he he
also made this point about
you know agency and a sort of like going
in and changing things and i think you
know in the
if you go all the way down the rabbit
hole of uh of thinking about fundamental
physics and things being time
you know reversible and etc you know
it almost turns into the point that
basically none of the interventions are
going to be possible because
everything is so tied together that you
can't move one thing without uh
and so that kind of says it seems like
it points to
at the end of the road that you're not
going to really be able to do such an
intervention unless you can only
consider a sub system
and that was exactly i think his point
is that if you consider a subsystem so
you can change something internally and
something externally has to
to you know uh react to for consistency
then you know then you start seeing
those kinds of interventions and a lot
of the ideas about causality start to
emerge
and that can be somewhat of the
resolution or i mean i think
he also briefly alluded to the fact that
or if you could make
a complete map of all interferences
like all the existing correlates
between variables right so that's uh
because when he was trying to contrast
the quantum case from
sort of classical cases he was saying
well you know the classical case
um you can actually map out
what all changes deterministically when
you change one thing
whereas in quantum mechanics that itself
is not often well defined
um so
yeah so um yeah but one
one point i i also wanted to comment on
this this notion of agency
i think that was that was not
highlighted in the previous
uh talk so in in so when you do
intervention it is really important that
the intervention is
independent so the agent who is
intervening is independent of the system
statistically independent otherwise uh
otherwise you you don't get this
the results that that i have presented
so intervention really
has to assume an agent sitting outside
and really deciding on on the state to
to intervene so
that sets some constraints on on on
agency on the other hand
the the creatures that we studied in
this robotics setting
these are agents so there is agency
and but these agents really before they
act
they receive some information from the
environment through their sensors and
then they act
and that's a kind of disconnect with the
theory so our
our agents but aren't they but don't
they have a set of formal instructions
already specified that if they if they
sense
x they can do y one y two or y
three it's finite if they sense z they
can do you know
with three possibilities so isn't that
i mean how is that independent
because they are already instructed
right i mean there's a yeah yeah yeah so
that's
that's what i'm saying they are not
independent
okay and we call them agents
and they would not be qualified this way
of lookup table of how
which actually to choose based on which
sensor input
would not be consistent with the
with with the notion of intervention
that i talked about yesterday
yeah so
[Music]
yeah yeah i know it's a i think that
probably uh
some fine fine-grained language there is
necessary
um yeah yeah i think at this point we
can open up to questions if there are
any questions from the audience
please feel free to indicate in the chat
that you want to ask a question and we
can unmute you
so may i also suggest so i
one thing i wanted to actually try to
draw a little bit
the the kind of reasoning that i
presented yesterday
maybe to um as a starting point for
further
questions or discussion that'll be great
so let me let me
try to connect my ipad
yeah it's a it's
a modification of the diagram that we
just saw
okay yeah so basically what i wanted to
so we had this diagram here oh this is
wonderful
i was just saying we miss a blackboard
so this is great
yeah so we had this uh prediction
and this is the data
[Music]
this is the theory
and then we had influence
so before i saw this diagram i actually
prepared another one
in order to illustrate what i have
presented yesterday
so basically we have a system
this and we want to understand that
system the inner working of that system
so we do experiments
and these experiments generate data
and with the data we can actually do the
inference
let me denote this by question mark so
that's the general paradigm
so the i think it was referred to as the
inverse problem
inference as the inverse problem from
the data and now the question is
uh what kind of experiments so
so now now i'm going to specialize this
a little bit
so this was the system was modeled in
terms of a causal
network
and then we had i presented yesterday
three kinds
of experiments one is simply
observation
and this creates
one type of data let's call it data one
and you can ask the question what can i
get from
just observing the system so that's one
one way to
to do experiments the second one is
intervention
and that generates a second kind of data
and you can ask the same question and
the thing that i did not
i had no time to talk about it is
sometimes you do experiments for example
in in
in the context of genotype phenotype
mapping you do knock out experiments you
knock out genes in order to understand
the function of the gene
and that's some kind that's some kind of
intervention
but basically it's a kind of structural
intervention you
remove parts of the system to see
the role of the gene you remove the gene
or block the gene
and then if you see an effect then you
change of the of the phenotype you see
ah that gene was responsible for
this uh phenotype and that was the thing
i was
wanted to talk about yesterday so that's
a knockout
so uh sunihat here i want you to clarify
so you know these cosmological
simulations that we do so i want both of
you to clarify for me
which kind of interventions are there
because i can see them being a normal
intervention
or a knockout because i can choose
parameters
you know there are a few numbers that
characterize a typical universe and then
you can evolve them
and i can choose a different set of
parameters and evolve different
universes
so in that sense it's knockout because i
can by hand
you know uh fix values
but then is it an intervention or is it
a knockout
i think a knockout would be maybe more
like if you were trying to understand
you know say how black hole i mean black
dark matters
sorry dark matter clumps in the universe
and the role of like gas
and baryons and stuff like that if you
just took out the gas
and re-ran the simulation that's sort of
like removing a whole mechanism and that
seems closer to a knockout to me um the
other one where you're just running the
simulation with different values of the
parameters to me that's uh
um well i mean it's sort of making a
prediction for different values of the
parameters of the theory if you wanted
you could think of that as
yeah and then there's a question is it
intervention or is it uh like uh
just conditioning but if that but
usually those parameters at the top of
the causal model right and i if i
professor i can correct me but and that
one of the examples he gave
if you intervene at the thing that's the
very parent then conditioning and
and interventions are the same so then
there's no distinction
um yeah i do i i think that's what i got
to is that right neha
yes i would say so yeah okay so but then
if i change the nature of dark matter
itself would that be
yeah i think there you get into a
question of are you thinking of your
when you think about theories do you
think of them as like you know
continuous parameters and
if you have two different theories
they're you know it's like a discrete
choice for
you know it's you can either think of
them as two different theories or you
can think of it as one theory with like
a discrete
parameter but like to me the structure
of inference
and and conditioning and do operations
aren't aren't changed
it's more about discrete and continuous
okay so maybe
we can move to the questions yeah no but
this
this was really nice the you know the
clarification of the
uh of the three kinds
of ways of generating data and therefore
the inference loops
and so to finish up you were saying that
so your argument is that the
way inference works in these three
kinds of causal systems is different
so my argument is that uh
in order to reveal the inner working of
the system you cannot just
observe it you need to apply different
kinds of
of experiments and
i got into this actually when i went to
the santa fe institute as a postdoc
and there i met jessica fleck who was
studying
primate societies and she was actually
liking the gene
knockout experiment she was actually
removing
some of these individuals from the
society and recording the changes of the
behavior in that society
in order to understand the the role
of that individual in the society
so that was very interesting so the idea
again i remove
structurally parts of the system
and then see what happens in order to
understand the function and that's
exactly like
the the idea of
that underlies gene knockouts but
i was puzzled by this whether we really
have a philosophical or conceptual basis
for this approach
of course the idea is if i change remove
something
and the behavior changes or the
phenotype changes
then i i understand the function that
was
that's basically the idea but i was not
sure whether there is some conceptual
foundation of it and then i tried to
understand it in terms of judea pearl's
causality theory
and it seems to me that we need more
than intervention
we really structural structural
perturbation of the system removal of
parts for example neurons in the brain
really
reveals some additional information
about about the system
that we cannot get simply by
intervention
and this is why yeah and the interesting
thing is that
uh the if i if i'm understanding it
correctly
that you know this knockout is not
actually
loss of information it is loss of a
particular kind of information that is
going to be
richer in terms of what it gives you uh
for data
exactly
yeah and i think this last part maybe is
that you so i agree about this last this
kind of complimentary set of diagrams
with the different types of experiments
that are being done
and i think if you go back to the
scientific method uh part of it what's
interesting is that uh
you know when when people just try to
decide what experiment to do
uh you know part of it is about trying
to come up with like the one that has
the most statistical power
you know uh within some you know kind of
just at the association level
but there's also a lot of you know a lot
of times the good experiments are kind
of would
reveal would be able to break a
degeneracy between say
two competing mechanisms right so you
have like two hypotheses for what the
graphical
model might look like they're both
consistent with the data that you have
thus far
and you're trying to build one that's
going to try to like make a sharp
distinction between those two and and
figuring out how to design them
you know uh you know a lot of times you
can just inspect the graph and kind of
if you know a little bit about what's
going on you have a pretty good idea
of what you should go do and that's
largely how experimentalists have done
things you just through intuition you
know like oh well if i do this that's
going to happen you know
and then and so that's pretty miraculous
and if you contrast that against
something like reinforcement learning
where you just like drive the car off
the cliff
a million times until it's a really good
you know race car driver or something
it's a
they're very different right and they uh
and um
and and then but then once you the other
part of that
you know side of that coin is if you do
an intervention and you you get some
data and it doesn't conform to what you
expect
in your your causal model maybe any of
them
then you're like you know what's going
wrong like i can exclude that theory but
that's not the end of the story right
you then
start generating new hypotheses and you
start trying to figure out like what
what is the new mechanism that could
potentially respond
in the way that i saw and uh and again
that's that type of
you know that imagination and the
hypothesis building
is not at the level of like running a
lot more low-level simulations it's at
this very like
high level you know big building block
course grain picture of what's going on
and uh and yeah that's so again i think
it's a place where you see that like
that's super core
to how we think about like children
playing you know it's
all about that i pushed the thing off
the the table a thousand times and you
know and
um and uh yeah so that interplay
is really interesting to me right and i
think
also um in the cases of you know
building these kinds of
uh physical models driven by physics it
could be i mean those are the places
kyle as you mentioned where
it could be revealed that you actually
have picked the wrong variables
you know these are not the
characteristic variables
that actually are salient to the
dynamics of the system
or to predict behavior right so
i think sometimes you get stuck in that
where
you suddenly do realize that um
when none of the causal networks uh
actually works
to explain the data that perhaps what
you have actually
chosen to generate the data are not the
right variables right that they don't
actually capture
all the features of the model
yeah yeah i mean the other thing i like
about that picture is you know when you
think about reductionism and emergence
and things like this
you can kind of think of them as
different different
causal models at different scales of
that you're thinking about a system
and maybe they're all connected but you
know the way the phenomena manifest
themselves look drastically different
right at the different scales and you
know ultimately if you could somehow
understand
you know the mapping between you know
the like the more the reductionist
causal model and the emergent one
like that's a fantastic if you can do
that and they're you know very
either occasionally we can do things
like that with like you know quarks and
gluons to protons to you know to you
know
atoms and molecules and you know like uh
occasionally we can
make that bridge uh but uh um if we
could
if we could get a lot better at that uh
um
and i think that's what the kind of
significance of a lot of this uh
machinery is
is that it's like kind of the necessary
step towards that path
i think we can probably continue
conversing let me quickly check in if
anyone has questions please don't feel
uh
shy and just type the question
in um and you know any kind of question
uh is uh is we are totally open
so don't feel like you have to ask a
question or a comment that is you know
highly impressive so i think
rob breckelmans has a question who said
that
i still need to dive into professor i's
work here but do you have any comments
on causal
information theory is this field well
developed or are there good reasons that
information theory is less useful or
relevant with interventional
distributions
so that's a very good question so um
i i think they are tightly coupled the
two theories
so um
originally when information theory was
invented by claude shannon he considered
he considered actually a channel channel
is a
that that's the term um uh
for for a markov kernel or
stochastic map so that's a mechanism so
he did consider a mechanism
but so there was the but it was a very
simple
setting sender and receiver okay so you
have x and y
and then you have an arrow between them
and you can compute the mutual
information the fundamental quantity
there is
the mutual information and the
information mutual information
is a kind of of mutual information rate
is a kind of
uh measure for the information flow from
x
to y now if you have this
this uh the situation that kyle was
referring to where you have a common
cause let's say you have
x y but they are influenced by z okay
and there is no information information
flow from x to y
but they are correlated so if you
compute the mutual information between x
and y
you would get a positive quantity but
you would
then assume okay there is information
flow from x to y which is wrong
okay but then the way we we corrected
this
is the following we said okay instead of
measuring the joint distribution of x
and y
by just observing it we have to
intervene in x
and observe y and when you do this
in the context of this common cause
example so z
is acting on x and y you intervene in x
and the distribution of y the condition
distribution of y given
x is simply the distribution of y
because it does not depend on x anymore
and the reason is that there is no error
from x to y
so if you do the interventional
conditioning you get a markov kernel
a channel that has no information flow
from x to y
and if you then after intervening in
this
after changing the notion of
conditioning
then use information theory then you get
the real
notion of causal information flow so
combining the notion of intervention
with classical information theory gives
you a nice
formalism to quantify causal information
flows
and this is what i did together with
daniel pollani actually
i hope this answers the question yeah
that was
really clear and wonderful
um anyone else any other questions
uh so before we um uh
conclude kyle did you have any final
questions did you
no no i think it's been a it's been a
fascinating discussion
um and i yeah i appreciate uh
appreciate being a part of it thank you
very much
so thanks mihaat and thank you kyle for
this wonderful
i will i could keep going for hours and
hours but i think um
that in the interest of everybody's the
value of everybody's time
uh we should wrap up our formal
conversation now
and i look forward to being in touch
with you professor i over as the project
unfolds and
we start actually we are hoping so kyle
is also part of our sort of core team of
people
so the first set of activities we have
for this project is a colloquium series
to really understand
different perspectives and how people
are thinking and post that we are hoping
in the future to actually
come up uh with ways to formally
understand
to get you know dive into the research a
little bit more and maybe come up with
the
new creative ways of thinking that might
benefit from a cross-disciplinary
learning
um uh and uh you know sort of vertical
you know sort of fertilizing
various methodologies so this was really
really
fun and useful thank you both and have a
wonderful weekend
thank you so much and thank you kyle for
this great introduction today
[Music]
yeah that's great yeah i i like uh
having it start off with
something grounded as well though oh
it's not all right
kyle we loved your slides so if you
don't mind sharing them that would be
great we'll just put them up as a medium
yeah
that would be great and thank you
everyone for uh attending so i want to
say thanks to the participants and to
tai
for helping um pull everything together
and to guy
for um smoothly managing uh
the recordings thanks everyone bye